in the final act and kyle rittenhouse's
murder trial this morning the jury
begins to decide the case after two
weeks of testimony and dramatic closing
arguments the 18 year old killed two
people during an anti-police protest in
kenosha wisconsin last year riddenhall
says he was defending himself nancy chin
is at the courthouse in kenosha nancy
good morning
nate good morning to you rittenhouse
could face life in prison yesterday the
judge allowed the jury to consider two
lesser charges in addition it would mean
less severe consequences but also make a
conviction more likely by the state
we shouldn't have 17 year olds running
around our streets with ar-15s
because this is exactly what happens in
closing arguments prosecutor thomas
binger portrayed kyle rittenhouse as an
instigator looking for trouble who
eventually found it prosecutors replayed
video of the moment he shot and killed
protester joseph rosenbaum before
running away towards the crowd and
police he does nothing to demonstrate to
the crowd that he isn't a threat to kill
again
and it turns out he does
after killing rosenbaum rittenhouse shot
and killed anthony hubert
and injured gage gross croits reinhaus
said both men attacked him but
prosecutors say the crowd believed he
was an active shooter
my client didn't shoot
at anyone until he was chased
and cornered while rittenhouse's
attorneys echoed his earlier claim of
self-defense i didn't do anything wrong
i defended myself but the prosecution
pointed to videos they say repeatedly
showed rittenhouse pointing his weapon
at demonstrators if you created the
danger
you forfeit the right to self-defense
the provocation instruction will really
become the linchpin of the jury's
deliberations
cbs legal analyst rikki kleeman says
that argument could be pivotal to the
jury's deliberations in the state of
wisconsin if you are the person who
provokes
the ultimate act of violence you have a
duty to retreat
kliman also tells us she expects
deliberations to either be very quick or
very long either way everyone here is on
close watch for a verdict there are 500
national guard troops on standby for
potential unrest tony
and we will be on standby as well nancy
thank you very much